2020 a été une excellente année pour les
titres technologiques sur les marchés
boursiers au canada l'indicé tsx de
technologies de l'information a augmenté
de plus de 80% quels sont donc les
entreprises technologiques à surveiller
en 2021 avec nous ce soir simon plantes
gestionnaire de portefeuille premier
vice-président à la financière banque
nationale bonsoir simon plan bonsoir
est ce que votre confiance dans les
actions technologiques demeure entière
ce soir il ya bien des investisseurs qui
se demandent toujours si une bulle
technologique
non c'est vraiment une question
pertinente parce que ça a été une année
spectaculaire 2020 il ya deux facteurs
un évidemment le colis d'accélérer la
pertinence de ses modèles d'affaires le
conjuguer avec toutes les politiques
monétaires budgétaires beaucoup de
liquidités ça provoque évidemment
beaucoup de demande pour ces titres leur
plus on voit vraiment des évaluations
très élevé exactement
mais si la pandémie fini par s'arrêter
est ce que est ce que ces titres là est
ce que ces actions technologiques vont
demeurer ad bon niveau selon vous mais
mon ma perception c'est que je pense que
vraiment une cadence qui était haussière
je serais pas surpris de voir un recul
parce qu'en ce moment les gens c'est
d'essayer d'évaluer le potentiel a
longtemps que ces sociétés là on était
là sont capables d'exécuter et du marais
paix kablan vizion b will tear peu
progressé mais entre-temps on sait
comment les marchés peuvent réagir
on pourrait voir les volets volatilité
par contre cela dit sur faiblesse
oui je serais intéressé parce que le coc
vidot mis l'accent sur le modèle
d'affaires de plusieurs d'entre elles
pillent une pertinence si on voit que
ces entreprises là je te mets en plus en
plus de place sur l'échiquier cédant
fossé des fleurons base au canada qui
peuvent avoir une place très
intéressantes sur les marchés internet
alors regardons cinq titres techno à
surveiller en 2021
cj de ses bottines axis litespeed
échapper faille va vous demander de nous
parler un peu de chacune de ces
entreprises commençons avec cgi dans le
secteur des solutions informatiques en
cg j'aime bien c'est une société plus
défensif
rae qui vécut un enjeu avec le co vite
parce que certaines entreprises
gouvernements ont gelé à des postes
budgétaires guardian transformation
numérique
par contre le fils et que ces dépenses
là vont revenir peut-être dans un pète
un peu plus tard au courant de l'année
voire même en 2022
donc c'est j'ai vraiment bien positionné
pour profiter de sa part une belle
exposition dans différents secteurs
industrie par le gouvernement à travers
à travers la terre
l'action est à 100 dollars ce soir de
cgi à la bourse de toronto de ses baux
est une plateforme numérique de traces
de formation en entreprise
ce qu'on peut voir c'est que de plus en
plus de gens bien évidemment comme un
travail de la maison puis ça va ça va
resté commerce en ligne prend beaucoup
plus de place aussi actuellement c'est
peut-être 15% des ventes au détail qui
se font en ligne qui va continuer à
progresser donc d'autres chevaux sur une
plateforme en ligne qui permet la
formation pour le consommateur pour les
partenaires d'affaires mais aussi pour
les employés
cette plateforme canadienne est vraiment
distingue par rapport ce qui est
disponible à travers le monde parce
qu'elle est vraiment intuitive le corps
nu peut être vraiment personnalisé donc
ce qu'on voit c'est une tendance de plus
en plus de la part des entreprises de
former entre autres les employés à
distance puis on vraiment belle
plateforme de quelle province cette
entreprise de chez hbo je crois que
basée à toronto toronto parfait qui
nexis maintenant ça c'est des logiciels
en gestion de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
oui exactement coville encore a mis la
lumière sur l'enjeu qu'on peut avoir sur
les chaînes d'approvisionnement
on parle ici d'un logiciel qui permet
vraiment d'optimiser l'utilisation qu'on
peut faire d'une chaîne
d'approvisionnement donc encore qu'il
n'existe une société vraiment
intéressante mais les quatre sociétés
qu'on contenterait discuter là on va
parler d'eux via tonight speech à
préfailles par contient jusqu'à mettre
la lumière c'est qu'actuellement
personnages trouvent les évaluations qui
sont relativement élevé mais c'est des
plans des entreprises qui ont vraiment
les plans d'affaires intéressant pour
les prochaines années alors pin axis
donc et à 180 dollars
ce soir litespeed sur une entreprise
québécoise système de points de vente et
commerce en ligne puis moi je dirais
chapeau à l'équipe de direction de
l'équipe et d'avoir pu voter
la tempête vraiment pour s'adapter à
cette nouvelle réalité dont ils ont
vraiment une capacité d'exécution
capacités aussi de faire des
acquisitions
donc beaucoup de place pour les
détaillants les restaurateurs pour
améliorer leurs empreintes digitales
plus l'altitude est vraiment une
solution intéressante est la championne
ne s'échappent et feuilles comme un
aimant auquel adam 1500 dollars
pratiquement d'action dans le 80 % de
performances mahé 18 chauffeurs poids
énorme mais actuellement juste pour
mettre les choses en perspective
je peux faire et se transige à peu près
50 fois pour les profits 50 fois son
chiffre d'affaires
puis fera vous avez parlé avec on
faisait référence amazon late show peut
faire vraiment de place pour le
commerçant de moyenne taille mais par
contre est ce beau conte quand amazon
qui en 2019 dépensé 60 milliards de
dollars us en logistique
on voit les deux premiers qui se fait au
québec donc elle a vraiment un défi mais
par contre la pertinence de ce plus en
plus de vendeurs veut faire affaire sur
une plateforme indépendante
comparativement à ce qu'amazon
d'infection est ce que vous surveillez
une entrée en bourse prochaine
actuellement on voit qu'il ya énormément
de sociétés québécoises ou canadiennes
qui songe entrant en bourse plus en plus
des mécanismes d'intégration directement
dans un marché où on parle aux états
unis espace de sociétés de capitaux de
démarrage donc faut réaliser que ça fait
dix ans que les sociétés technologiques
ses finances dans les marchés privés
pile enfin on a plusieurs introductions
donc il va avoir probablement été
intéressante à regarder cela n'est
parfait or suisse de près merci beaucoup
pour cet éclairage ce soir simon plantes
merci merci aura pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit